[Music]
Tamizh this neighborhood was a labor of
hate for many people here so I thought
that we should celebrate with an art
form that we literally invented here in
the bad place the comedy roast I see
Jason Mendoza's here Jason might not be
the smartest guy in the world but he is
the dumbest guy in the world
Oh Jason buddy all you had to do was to
keep quiet but you couldn't stop talking
about Kendall Jenner or that dumb
quarterback horse his name there bortles
always ranting about Derek bortles lucky
for you my friend Jaguars games are the
only ones televised in the bad place
hey cuz I saw no way don't all we need
is a defense and an office and some real
changes don't take it personally it just
has to put on a show for the other
dinners too honey
al Jamil elegance grace sophistication
but enough about your sister you know
what the worst moment of two hotties
life was when the last song played at
one of her parties and she would run off
and cry because she still hadn't won her
parents approval the worst moment of
Donnie's life every other moment of her
empty pointless life
I see Eleanor she'll strap is here
Eleanor and I have a lot in common
here's how you can tell us apart one of
us is a manipulative demon who's an
expert at making other people miserable
and then the other one is made you
thought you deserved a medium place like
Mindy st. Claire are you kidding me
you're bad Eleanor this is exactly the
place you should be that's super funny
for a roast there bud
oh sorry you want a joke okay you love
Chiti and she doesn't love you back
that's funny because it's very cruel and
humiliating I consider you one of my
closest parents speaking of cheating is
something no one has ever said because
no one talks about cheating because no
one likes cheating because he's so
annoying about ethics
now when you taught the trolley problem
did you secretly wish that it could be
you who wound up under the trolley
because all your students did Oh
Chiti sorry I got a joke for you but
knock knock who's there he died alone
because you couldn't commit to anyone
that along because you couldn't commit
to anyone that's all my time let's tear
this mother
so maybe I was wrong and Michael isn't
on our side
[Applause]
you